قتل في السابع والعشرين من مارس من السنه
الماضيه جنديان اسرائيليان واصيب عشره حين
اطلق فلسطين النار على افراد من الشرطه
الاسرائيليه في الخضيره بمنطقه حيفا
وبعد يومين من عمليه الخضيره قتل خمسه
مستوطنين واصيب اخرون حين نفذ اسير
فلسطيني سابق هجوما مسلحا في ابن باراك
غير بعيد عن تل ابيب
وفي السابع من ابريل من العام الماضي قتل
ثلاثه مستوطنين واصيب اكثر من عشره في
هجوم مسلح استهدف شارع ديزنك في قلب تل
ابيب قتل المهاجم بعد ساعات في مسجد
بمدينه يافا بعد اشتباك مع مجموعه من جنود
الشباب وافراد الشرطه
وفي الخامس من مايو قتل ثلاثه اسرائيليين
واصيب اربعه في هجوم مسلح بمدينه العاد
وذكرت الشرطه الاسرائيليه في وقت لاحق ان
منفذي الهجوم فلسطينيين من بلده الرمانه
بالضفه الغربيه وقد جاء الهجوم بالتزامن
مع عوده قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي الى
اقتحام باحات المسجد الاقصى
في الثامن من اكتوبر الماضي قتلت مجنده
اسرائيليه وجرح خمسه مجندين في عمليه
استهدفت حاجزا في مدينه شعفاط شمال القدس
وقد جاءت العمليه بعد 11 يوما من الحصار
الذي فرض على شعفاط والمناطق القريبه منها
وفي التاسع من مارس الجاري اصيب خمسه
اشخاص في عمليه اطلاق نار بشارع ديزنكوف
وسط تل ابيب وجاءت العمليه بعد قتل قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي ثلاثه فلسطينيين خلال
اقتحامها بلده جبع جنوب مدينه جنين وقد
اعلنت حركه حماس ان عمليه تل ابيب رد على
جرائم الاحتلال في جبع وجنين وتوعدت بمزيد
من الضربات الموجعه